ever since I started reviewing the fold
I've had this sort of tumultuous
relationship with the phone now when it
first came out I was blown away by the
technology I mean this is the future of
smartphones and I thought it was
fantastic then the full two three and
four have come out subsequently and they
have improved the device somewhat
but the form factor was relatively the
same very elongated had this prominent
gap between the two displays a lot of
things would get inside of it that means
I had to carry it inside of a pouch in
the inside of my pocket so I wouldn't
get any lint or any sort of coins or
anything that would scratch the inside
display another manufacturers came to
Market with foldable devices that
improved on Samsung's initial offering
so when the full five came about
I was somewhat apprehensive about it I'm
like okay I'll give it a shot but I have
to you know acknowledge a few things on
this first and foremost they've improved
this phone a lot of my complaints are
fixed here on the full five zero Gap
hinge that means both displays are
essentially flat against each other and
that makes it a lot more durable and a
lot more robust carrying it in your
pocket or just going day to day with it
also we have Flagship specs in this
phone Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 processor
inside of this which arguably you could
say that other manufacturers don't put
Flagship specs inside of their foldable
phones they usually get a processor
that's about a year or two behind and
then cameras that aren't really up to
Snuff that's not the case with this now
the cameras may not be you know the s23
uh Flagship level but they're very good
now that the same cameras as last year
but with the new enhancements with the
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 the more robustness
of the phone overall and the design how
is as a Content Creator's tool could
this be your only phone or would you
rather go for the flip 5.
let's talk about that right now
so let's talk about the cameras on the
fold five now they're relatively the
same as last year's full that's where
you're getting a 50 megapixel for your
main you've got a 12 megapixel for your
Ultra wide and 10 megapixel for your
telephoto Zoom to go all the way up to
30 times or that's with some digital
Zoom involved but I think it's three
times for optical then if you want to
use the selfie camera on the outside
it's 10 megapixels and they have also
have an underneath camera and the inside
for four megapixels it's a lot of
cameras in a phone now here's the thing
the specs are relatively the same as the
fold 4 but we're now running the
Snapdragon 8th Gen 2 which in theory
should allow us to have a little bit
better picture quality does it for the
most part it's almost the same
you may get a little bit more I guess in
terms of the video functionalities in
terms of processing and speed but the
image quality is
decent I mean this is not Flagship like
the Galaxy s23 series but it's
definitely good enough for day-to-day
photography video as well now there is a
little bit of a lag when I was testing
this out I'll show you that in just a
bit when I was using the camera system
in terms of the shutter when it was
snapping the photo that's a little bit
of a hindrance because nowadays with
smartphones you want it to be Snappy
exactly you press that button it
actually takes the photo there's a
little bit of a delay I'm not too sure
if this will be fixed on a firmware
update or not but it is something to
take note of but overall as you're going
to see from the sample images the image
call is good you get those vibrant
Samsung colors they look really good the
portrait mode is decent on this as well
I'm gonna take a picture of Zach he's in
a tank top right now looking swollen
he's been working out he's been begging
me to take his photo he's like Bobby
please take a photo for me please please
I need it for my Tinder I need it for my
other dating apps and I'm like all right
Zachy fine not like you don't have
enough girls already but I'll give you
another option here we go so here's a
picture of Zacky in all his glory and
you get an idea of how this looks in the
portrait mode again it's decent it's
digitized a little bit or is having a
one inch sensor as we test it on other
phones is gonna give you a better
overall look
but I think for day-to-day usage and for
majority of people out there these
cameras are pretty decent anyway Let's
test some video with the front facing
cameras right now so now we're gonna do
the front-facing camera video test I'm
gonna walk through this tunnel here this
is going to give you an idea of some
really bad Acoustics to see how it picks
up how it isolates the voice because
Samsung's done a pretty good job at this
in the past with their phones let's see
how it goes right now so I'm now
recording at 4K 30 with the front facing
camera we've got these ladies that are
walking in from the other side so
there's going to be a lot of noise in
this tunnel this is more of a stress
test to see how this performs now it is
exposing relatively well I mean it's a
little bit brighter in the back because
of course this is outdoors and this is
indoors but it's trying to expose for my
face and it's doing a relatively good
job so far the colors look great
exposing for the clouds relatively well
everything looks well balanced and I'm
walking up the steps here now Zaki is an
ultimate gimbal look at this guy he's in
flip-flops as he's carrying the camera
and the gimbal look at that guy
multitasking multi-purpose what a
machine you he's the Terminator of
cameraman I'll be back
with a bigger gimbal yes but anyway
um as we're walking you're seeing this
it all looks smooth here on my on my
display Samsung displays are fantastic
we know that already colors look good
it's a little bit contrasty a little bit
more than I'm used to seeing but again
that might be just the display that I'm
looking at right now let us know in the
comment section below what you see on
the computer screen here but uh so far
not too bad we're gonna record video AK
as I'm talking to see how the mic sound
how the stabilization is let's get down
to it okay
I am recording here with the rear
cameras here eight k30 okay Maxine out
here on the full five and do we need AK
video a lot of people say no we don't
necessarily but if you're going to do
some cropping if you want some
flexibility in your video 8K definitely
helps in that way but of course you're
going to see a lot more detail and I
don't have any beauty mode stuck on this
thing so you're gonna see all my
imperfections but you know what that's
part and parcel with life right exactly
but overall I gotta say uh yeah I think
the video quality looks relatively good
AK auto focus is good which is great
some of the flagship phones are not
doing autofocus as well as others
Samsung has no issues in that regard and
I think we got ourselves a winner here
especially when it comes to video on the
fold five so now I'm testing out the
camera inside the display which is
underneath so already right now I'm
noticing a little bit of a difference in
terms of the image quality it looks a
little bit more I don't say muddy but
it's softer so if you want that more of
that Streisand Beauty effect you want to
look a little bit younger naturally this
might be the camera to go for but you
lose a little bit of that punch in terms
of color but overall I mean this doesn't
feel as you're holding it open up like
this because it's so thin and it's so
slippery with the bezels I would
definitely need a case for this as a
matter of fact I'm going to use this for
two hands just to be safe but uh yeah
keep in mind this is some newer
technology that's under the display
camera system and I think it'll improve
over time but right now it's decent but
I would just prefer the other camera
that I use for the original front-facing
uh selfie and video so I wanted to
attribute I want to talk about here is
the folding system in terms of using a
photography or video now on other
smartphones out there when you go into
this mode you're going to see your view
your display here at the bottom you can
actually snap photos here unfortunately
you see it on top so if I'm in this mode
I can't see anything I see my buttons to
take a photo or video but that's all I
see I can see the reference image on the
side once it's taken but seeing where my
framing is at is very very difficult
especially outside it would have been
better in my personal opinion is
actually if the viewfinder or the
display showing your subject was here
and then you could shoot accordingly and
then of course you could see your final
image there I don't know personal
preference but to me it doesn't work as
well as let's say the flip 5 or other
foldable devices out there which leads
me to
my point about the full Vibe and content
creation are you a flip person or all
you're going to be a full person I'll
tell you who I am right after this quick
message from our sponsor this video is
brought to you by MSI meet the summit E6
and flip featuring the latest 12th gen
Intel i7 processor RTX 30 series
graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD Plus
touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime so
am I a full guy or am I a flip guy you
know and this is a question I've been
asking myself for quite some time but
after the latest versions of the Galaxy
fold 5 and flip 5 I've come to a
decision I am a flip person versus a
fool now that's not to say this is a bad
phone it's not it's a very good phone
for what it is designed to be and that
is content consumption content creation
I would say Z flip 5 because of the form
factor how you can use it in camcorder
mode you can go waste level waste level
viewfinder for photography or video with
different ways of capturing your
subjects and creating some really unique
shots with the full five not so much as
you just saw recently it's really
difficult to use it in that way it's
primarily designed to be used in a candy
bar mode especially when you're taking
photos and videos which is fine because
that's how most of our phones are
nowadays but I would have liked to have
seen Samsung really try to do more with
this foldable design especially when it
comes to content creation but that's
what the flip 5 is for but day-to-day
usage I've enjoyed this phone for
Content consumption watching YouTube
videos you know browsing the web the
speakers on this phone are fantastic
they're loud really good dynamic range
inside of them the colors on the screen
are vibrant watching YouTube videos or
Netflix is awesome no issues at all with
that I've really enjoyed using it and
especially as a tablet device you want
to do multitasking and split screens
it's great in that way but to be honest
with you for my day data usage I don't
always use all those things I'm still
primarily used to a candy bar phone so I
just used one app at a time and when I'm
done with it I close it out and open
another one so I'm not really utilizing
the power of the fold five at least for
my personal usage and you may be
different and if you are I agree and I
think there's a lot of benefits to this
um I wish that Samsung did create or
give us some sort of casing inside the
box and you know a little bit better
presentation because you're spending
eighteen hundred US Dollars they're
about even more depending on a premium
device but outside of that this has been
a really beautiful phone to use but I
have to say
between this and the flip five I'm a
flip kind of guy anyway guys those are
my thoughts on the full fight let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below if you like this video
subscribe to the channel and check out
more of our videos right here